we had heard from the Indonesian
president Widodo on this we also share
he just got some headlines from Tony
Fernandez the AirAsia CEO who has been
very much communicating with the public
through his Twitter account and he's now
made some more comments about the about
the accident and what they found what
does he said so far well right now Tony
Fernandez he is just telling the public
that this is a terrible moment for him
and AirAsia of course he's the founder
of the airline that hasn't had a single
accident a single fatality since it was
founded back in two thousand one now
Fernandez is known to have a rather
flamboyant personality well he's taking
a very very serious tone now odd thing
also through his Twitter account that
words cannot express how sorry he is and
that he will do whatever he can to
support the effort the search and rescue
operations going on in Indonesia now
turning into recovery effort buddy and
as I mentioned we heard from the
president as well and he briefed the
public on these recovery efforts how has
Indonesia so far compared really to
Malaysia and that's one flight mh370 how
has how has it been that he's been
handling situation what's been the
assessment so far well Indonesia has
been leading the search and rescue
operation which as I said earlier it has
now turned into recovery effort and
president Widodo just pointing that out
there now focusing on recovering
passengers crew members with all those
says that more ships are heading to the
crash site and that they will deploy the
assets needed for a massive recovery
effort now with although has been on the
ground he's trying to talk to relatives
in Surabaya where he just gave a press
briefing to the public there he has been
getting though help from neighboring
countries as well as the United States
China Malaysia just some of the
country's contributing ships and planes
of course all of these country
here in Asia having some experience from
those Malaysia airline crash that
happened earlier this year now Indonesia
media though has been criticized for its
coverage of the tragedy graphic images
of a body floating at sea were shown on
television relatives in waiting areas
all these images and some reportedly
fainted and had to be taken to hospital
now the bodies that are being retrieved
from the crash site will be sent to
Surabaya where the president is now for
identification and officials there will
give an update on the recovery process
tomorrow more